millions marched in Paris on Sunday in
solidarity with France and for many
world leaders it was a photo-op too good
to pass up
reporters without borders has called
some of these leaders predators because
their press freedom records are well
pretty crappy hypocritical much you
decide Jordan's King Abdullah and his
wife Queen Rania must have gotten
temporary amnesia when it comes to their
own country's abysmal Press Freedom
ranking the country has blocked more
than 260 websites can put you behind
bars for three years for insulting the
king and has used anti-terrorism laws to
imprison journalists guests free speech
is cool as long as it happens in someone
else's country Turkish Prime Minister
Ahmet Davutoglu also managed to squeeze
in even though Turkish authorities fired
or forced the resignations of almost 60
journalists who covered the occupy gezi
protests back in 2013
oh and Turkey also blocked Twitter and
YouTube in the lead-up to the 2014
elections then there's Egypt which has
consistently ranked as one of the top 10
deadliest countries in the world to be a
journalist but that didn't stop egypt's
foreign ministers Sameh Shoukry from
showing up in paris air media outlets
reported he was at the March even though
we can't find any photos of him there
hmm thank you remember that Egypt jailed
more than 200 journalists in 2014
including three of our own colleagues
Russian Foreign Minister Sergey Lavrov
was also reportedly in Paris but m.i.a
from any pictures I don't know what's
currently worse Russia's free speech
record or it's tanking ruble the
government has cracked down on political
activists and anti-corruption blogger
Alexei Navalny sparking protests in his
name and at least 20 journalists have
been murdered since Vladimir Putin first
became president in 2000 oh end did we
mention a law banning so-called gay
propaganda doesn't quite sound like free
speech does it when you think press
freedom you probably think Bahrain why
you don't reference foreign minister
Khaled bin Ahmed Al Khalifa and Prince
Abdullah bin Hamad al-khalifa
represented the country in Paris but
reporters without borders ranked the
Kingdom 163 out of
eighty-four press freedom in part
because of the government's ongoing
crackdown on anyone critical of the
monarchy protests have actually been
going on for four years finally an
unlikely duo from the embattled Holy
Land Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and Palestinian Authority
President Mahmoud Abbas Netanyahu
literally crashed the March after French
president Francois Hollande actually
asked him not to come but the bigger
faux pas here is Netanyahu's hypocrisy
because just this past summer at least
seven journalists were killed on his
watch during Israel's bombardment of the
Gaza Strip the Israeli army has even
acknowledged it targeted journalists and
media buildings in the past meanwhile
not best March - even though journalists
back home have been imprisoned for
supposedly insulting him in fact only
thirty percent of the Palestinian
public's say people in the West Bank can
criticize the Palestinian Authority
without fear but hey does your dirty
laundry back home really matter as long
as you look principled on the
international stage as they say in
French we